all right joining us now for more on our
top story Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter investigative reporter author
it's out soon July is coming the Russian
hoax areas gregg jarrett fox news legal
analyst Greg let's start with the
hearings today with what as you dig
deeper into the IG report all you see
are all these Trump aiding lead
investigators and then the very same
people they put the fix in and rig what
would have put any other American in
jail with Hillary and then they
immediately go start the Russia
investigation on Trump does that then
disqualify and and and put into doubt
from the Gecko the Muller witch-hunt oh
it absolutely does and as Jonathan
Turley pointed out there's no possible
way that Muller can pursue obstruction
of justice against President Trump
because both the IG and the acting
Attorney General have said Comey richly
deserved to be fired but today's best
moment really happened on the
cross-examination by Senator Lindsey
Graham what he said I'm not buying this
inspector general the bias at the FBI
was so severe so pervasive it had to
influence the decision to clear Hillary
Clinton and he pointed to the
exoneration statement that come he
initially found Clinton guilty under the
Espionage Act but somebody changed the
language ever so slightly in that
emendation allowed Comey to exonerate
Clinton when in fact she had committed a
crime you know the swamp answer Sarah as
it relates to oh we're not gonna second
guess prosecutorial discretion as they
call it here that well tell that to
Christian saucier because he did far
less and he spent a year in jail and
there are many other examples that we
pointed out on a program here and what's
interesting is he won't make that
determination but then the entire report
just example after example of blatant
corruption and bias by the top people
involved in this and how much they love
hilary
protect her and then the same people
take a sledgehammer and and literally
try and destroy Trump from the get-go
Shawn I think this was such an important
hearing today and Greg's right on the
money I think Senator Graham gave the
best cross-examination ever and there
were a number of things that came out of
that that exoneration that change in
language actually appears to be the
insurance policy that Peter struck was
talking about with Lisa Paige his
paramour in those text messages remember
they were looking for an insurance
policy in another text message and in
that same text message let me go back to
that they talked about Andy's office
Andy McCabe so it would be deputy
director Andrew McCabe and the most
important question was the one that
Senator Graham asked was Andrew McCabe
in that meeting with Peter struck and
Lisa Paige and we need to know that from
strucken page those two need to be
interviewed and then Andrew McCabe needs
to be interviewed again because if
that's the case if he was in that
meeting this is the most frightening
frightening example of FBI power since
Edgar Hoover and Americans should be
terrified of it because they were
rigging an election and that's the whole
point here that's why it's the biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal ever
the similarities though in terms of of
the Muller investigation and the Hillary
rigged investigation are eerie in this
way Greg Jarek it as much as you have
all of these same people that that have
been exposed here and then you look at
jeanne ray and Andrew Weissman and all
the Democratic donors it's the same
corruption that will only be exposed
down the line although we've known for a
long time in Robert Muller's witch-hunt
it's no different it sort of makes you
wonder are the only people who actually
work the FBI Peter struck Lisa Paige
Andy McCabe and James Comey and after
all they commandeered this case two main
justice away from the field office why
did they do that because they wanted to
control it and it was also being
controlled by the Obama White House that
is abundantly clear and yes Muller
assembled a team of partisans some of
whom were also in on the Hillary Clinton
fence all right all of this is now this
is the beginning of the process and a
lot of these people are in deep trouble